man muss beim us-präsidenten natürlich
auch davon ausgehen was passiert wenn er
tatsächlich jetzt stirbt warten was wie
wir die situation in den usa dann die
situation es gab diese fälle bereits
also wir wissen abraham lincoln wurde
ermordet als er präsident war also
während seiner amtszeit genauso john f
kennedy als amtierender präsident
erschossen in beiden fällen hat damals
der vizepräsident übernommen auch wenn
es damals noch nicht offiziell geregelt
wurde im fall von john f kennedy war es
beispielsweise so dass seinen
stellvertreter johnson übernommen hat
und dann wiederum aber der posten des
vize-präsidenten offen blieb für zwei
jahre bis die nächste legislaturperiode
begann
und da hat man dann festgestellt weil
die anderen ja rangfolge 3 und 4 ich
habs grad genannt
der speaker of the house und der
präsident des senats waren schon weit in
ihren 80ern und damals hat man sich
überlegt man muss das mal ordentlich
regeln das wirklich dann auch ein
weiterer vize präsident ins amt kommt
darauf wurde im jahre 1960 dann das
fünfundzwanzigste management erlassen
also ein zusatz zur verfassung das eben
regelt was passiert wie genau läuft das
also der vizepräsident übernimmt dann
die amtsgeschäfte
und es gab auch schon andere fälle in
der vergangenheit also beispielsweise
hat wilson einen schlaganfall erlitten
im amt 1919 war das und war danach
halbseitig gelähmt man hat damals aber
versucht seinen gesundheitszustand zu
verheimlichen sein amtsarzt der auch
gleichzeitig mit ihm befreundet war hat
sich geweigert ihn als amtsunfähig aus
zu erklären und seine frau hat dann
teilweise aufgaben übernommen was
natürlich verfassungsrechtlich auch sehr
schnell
also es ist nicht nichts was man nicht
passiert ist natürlich hoffen wir dass
diese fälle jetzt in diesem fall nicht
eintreten